thanks to the EPA and Capri had a lot of
constructive discuss discussions during
the past couple of weeks and I suppose
we have a good solution package now and
we will offer that to the EPA on
Wednesday do you think the market will
breathe a sigh of relief when you
finally come out with a number a final
number on how much this is going to cost
as the question is what it will cost so
for the to the repair because we have a
estimation of about six point seven
billion euro so we accept that should be
enough for the global situation it's a
difficult situation as you know we have
a lot of generations of engines to
prepare for the for the problem and you
know we hope that we will have an
agreement with EPA and cop as soon as
possible will you have to buy do you
think a lot of the cars back as a result
of the problems in theory it's possible
and at the end it's result of the
negotiations and folks we will have to
open cover so a lot of your brands have
been incredibly successful here howdy
obviously Porsche Volkswagen has had its
problems even before this emissions
crisis what will you do to try and win
back market share in that segment in the
US as opposed with folks one we should
have a better understanding of the
American customers and market so we have
installed and Development Department in
Chattanooga as well and we do a lot of
more of market research to see how the
customer in America does what the cost
for the future and one example is behind
us and we will have more new models in
the future and of course first one is
intends to prepare the automotive future
more active than before I've been to the
Chattanooga factory it is incredibly
precise and efficient ecologically sound
do you expect to continue to employ
everyone who works there we are very
proud of the factory and also of the
5000 employees we have there and now
we're investing in another SUV model
more than 900 million u.s. dollar and we
will create more than two thousand
employees for the future so it's a nice
story let me finally ask you about
brands you have many that are near and
dear to my heart including Lamborghini
and Ducati do you expect to be able to
keep these brands or will you possibly
have to sell some of them off there's no
doubt that we are very lucky with all 12
brands and we will keep it for the
future as well